I definitely posted a lot during launch week and a lot of you guys who have subscribed for vlogs or cooking videos
More like, "What's happening!" but for most of you guys who know me, I'm sure you weren't surprised
I plan on doing the week with iPhone
But I felt like I had posted so many videos within a week that I thought maybe I would just wait and do it two
Weeks with iPhone so here we are, it's been about two weeks since I got the iPhone X
It really is
A beautiful device so the first week that I had it was basically filming and shooting and editing videos about the phone
So I didn't really feel like I got a chance to try it out and use it in sort of an everyday normal
Setting like I normally would so don't trying our testing week
We tried out a bunch of things. The first thing that we tried out that I didn't even share on my channel because my sister
post of the video is we did an underwater test, "Would face ID work underwater?" And number two, "Would your phone actually work underwater?"
And the answer is no. It doesn't. The screen doesn't work on water. Since this was our video
She volunteered to use her phone to do this test. Currently her phone is still working perfectly fine. The iPhone X is rated to be able
To withstand at least thirty minutes underwater, it's recommended that you don't go past 3.3 feet
Which thankfully the pool that we were in was about 3 feet cuz my sister dropped her phone, and we both like
It for him to be quite difficult to go underwater
Try to keep your eyes open while swiping up and trying to see if the phone is actually
Responding to your face in this test we did conclude that the phone does not work underwater
You weren't able to swipe up it also didn't recognize her face
We did have some difficulties with face ID trying to recognize each of us with sunglasses on in very bright conditions
so the reason for this is because if it's super reflective the phone is unable to see your eyes in this bright light and if
You have the attention awareness on, if it can't see your eyes
It's not gonna unlock your phone. The way that you can get around
This is turning off the attention to awareness so basically you won't have to look at your phone this does make face ID a little
Bit less secure so that means if somebody comes up to you
They can swipe up and unlock your phone with attention awareness on if somebody tried to do that to you
You would have to be looking at it for it to unlock
It has been a little bit frustrating when I'm outside walking my dog with my sunglasses on and it's super bright
And I'm trying to use face ID and it's not unlocking him, and he's pulling me super hard going to the bathroom
And then I'm trying to clean the bathroom up
But I'm trying to use my phone and unlock it and it's not working. So normally effectively
I'm going to be in a situation where I'm gonna have sunglasses on it's super bright
I do turn off the attention awareness, but for the most part,
I have been keeping it on because it is an extra layer of security. Other than that I've been pretty impressed with face ID I
Know a lot of people have been saying with they're having problems some of my friends. They're saying it's not recognizing me
It's taking too long
Even at first my sister was having an issue where it was taking a while to recognize her
And I think the reason for this is a lot of people when they first set up their phones
It says hey its face ID times, set it up. and you're kind of in a hurry you want to set up your phone
You're not really paying attention. You're just sort of moving your head around and I feel like that first set up
It doesn't get a really good read on your face. So if you are having this problem
I definitely recommend going back in
Rescanning your face and seeing if that helps. Another thing that I tried was what if I looked like a zombie, what if my face was uncompletely recognizable?
Well face ID recognized me. I decided to go all out
I had this incredible special effects makeup artist Dan Gilbert come to my house
make me look like a zombie and see, if we could fool, the face ID. Now one of the things that I read in the
Comments is a lot of you guys are
Suspect because you sent Justine during this whole process, you were unlocking your face from beginning to end, and the thing with face ID is
It learns your face. So perhaps this entire time that I was getting my makeup done I was unlocking my phone
Maybe the phone was learning my face throughout the whole process, which is of
Very very very very a valid point and that I don't really know
I don't know if that's the case. Now the reason that I decided to obscure most of the bottom of my face is because that
Previous day that I'd met Dan we did something for another shoot where I was a zombie
and I obscured most of my eyes and most of my forehead so I thought I've been unlocked with most of the top of my
Face I'm scared
It's gotta be something down here
One of the things that I did notice is that when you turn off the attention awareness is it's not actively seeking for your eyes
So it doesn't lock your phone a little bit faster, so again if you are having some issues with it unlocking slow
or it's out recognizing your face try turning that off try rescanning and
Let me know if that works for you. Going back to the sunglasses
I tested out probably like 15 to 20 pairs of sunglasses to see if they would unlock
But I was right here in a controlled environment where there's no sunlight, it's my studio light. So with that
I'm not having a lot of reflection so all those sunglasses worked indoors
But did they work outdoors and not so much
I also heard that people were saying if they are able to unlock their phone using their reflection in the mirror
Hmm, let's try it
It unlocked
Yes, it works! So it looks like face ID does work with a reflection of yourself in the mirror
Interesting. But it doesn't work with a printed picture of yourself. One of the things that I was worried about with this phone is because
It's so much smaller
And I was so used to having the plus size phones that I wasn't going to like this as much as I do
Surprisingly having a smaller phone is incredible
I can fit it so much easier into my purses, into my pants pockets, into my yoga pants
I've got like a little side pocket thing when I'm running or hiking or not really running
Closely if just walking the dog around the block
it's so great to not have such a
Massive phone like I previously did. So the form factor of the X is comparable to an iPhone 8 or any of those phones that
Are that size but the screen size is actually larger than the iPhone 8 plus. Which kind of puts this in the most perfect,
Sweet spot for the size of a phone. I know what you're saying, "What about the notch?" "Do you love it?"
"Do you hate it?" Honestly
I am not really sure, I feel like I'm kind of 50/50 because there are some times where I'm like man
Just don't trying to watch something and then as little notch is there and it's like why are you there just?
For then other times it does fit pretty seamless with apps
so I don't really notice it, but to say that I don't notice it all, I would completely be lying because
It's there, like I don't know how you
Can't see it like if you don't see this, then I don't know what you're looking at because it's there the knotch is there.
But if they were to remove the knotch, I don't think I would be upset at all
I think that I would be okay if it wasn't there
I mean I see why they have to have the notch here because there's really nowhere else to put it if they didn't put the
Notch there, then there would have to be some sort of a black bar up here
Just to house everything that is inside of this notch, proximity sensor, it has the true depth camera,
Speakers can't it's got so many things inside of that little notch today
I mean I get it, but how are they gonna get rid of it for the next phone, or are they not?
Or is this is this the new normal I?
Thought that I would be taking a ton of front-facing portrait selfies, but to be honest
I really haven't taken very many I guess in the past week
I've just kind of been playing call of duty, so that's really not something that's very interesting to take pictures of. Especially a front-facing selfie
My friend Joey said he's returning his iPhone X, No.1, because he wasn't a huge fan of the face ID and No.2, because
The camera quality was too good
And I a hundred percent get where he's coming from because when you take a front-facing picture now. I mean it sees everything
It's like, "What?!"
I've taken tons of photos of my dog
I've taken what if I had been taking pictures of I don't even know honestly since I got through the iPhone released week
I've basically been playing video games, and it's been great, so yeah, I'm looking through here
I haven't really done a whole lot the past few days
Here is a cute picture of
My baby boy doggy and his friend Yossi. Fires picture my wine fridge while that's really exciting
Oh, here's a picture of me and Alex Clark we did a fun video the whisper challenge video
And we unboxed a very fun the Star Wars Jedi Challenge game
What else are some wine, got a LAN party, more pictures the dog? Yeah, I basically have
Done a lot. So other than taking pictures my dog. I've been very very impressed with the new snapchat filters now granted
I don't
really use
Snapchat as much as I used to I feel like most of the time when I'm going to post something on snapchat
I end up just posting it on my Instagram stories
But I decided to hop into snapchat and test out to the face tracking features that they have now
With some of their face filters, and they are very very accurate. I was very shocked. Hey guys. How's it going?
I'm just shooting some videos here, but I was testing out a new snapchat
He's tracking on the iPhone 10
So like it's very very and it's like here's another one with glasses on like look at this like I move it and it does
I'm so impressed. I'm impressed. Oh yeah, this is
This is great
One thing that snapchat did right is get in early get the face tracking features and really implement that to the max on snapchat
Let's see what else have I been doing I mean the phone is obviously so much faster than the 7 although
I did kind of have that middle phone
I had the iPhone eight between the X so having the jump from the 8th to the X
Didn't really have an overall feeling of that much difference because both of those phones the insides are basically the same thing
Also the camera quality on the 8 is almost identical to the 10 being able to have the slo-mo options to go up to 240
At 1080 is pretty great although
I don't really use it that often
But I have found that I've been vlogging a lot more on my iPhone because every time I go to vlog
I either don't have my vlogging camera
Or the battery is dead and a lot of you guys didn't really notice a difference when I went from this to the other one
of course I can tell because I'm the one filming and editing and the front-facing camera on here is obviously not as good as the
4k SONY that I used to film with, but overall the audio on this thing is great the video quality looks amazing. The photos look
Incredible almost too good and too realistic. The battery life,
I haven't really noticed
That it's been worse than the 8 or the 7 mostly because I'm always carrying around a movie, so I am unaware of
battery life ever
I don't know if it even gets close
To being read I'm plugging this thing in I've also really loved having wireless charging pad one by my bed
By my desk over there, and I even have this one over here, which has been my charger of choice the Mophie
Wireless charger, so I use this one of my desk and this one
I kind of just move around throughout the house wherever I happen to be and in my bedroom. I have the Belkin one
I'm not really sure why I decided to do that
I feel like I like the look of this one and it's a lot smaller than the Belkin
I have some white lamps in my bedroom, so I felt like the white matched a little bit better
But it really is nice. Just being able to roll over from my phone on the charger
I don't have to worry if it's plugged in or if the dogs gonna jump down and knock a cord off the bed
It's been pretty great so I know welcome
Justine to wireless charging why did the pixel to?
Decide not to do wireless charging. I'm so confused
I feel like they rushed the pixel to out just to be like here's our phone here it is
It's ready, but it wasn't it wasn't ready. I will say the front-facing pixel to portrait mode is really really good
I did a couple tests of that and I'll be doing a future video here
Hopefully very very soon of the note 8 the pixel 2 and the iPhone X doing a little photo comparison video comparison
I know a bunch of people have already done it
But I'm a little bit late either way even if I didn't do this video for you guys
I would be doing this for myself anyway, so I just kind of want to test it out and see for myself
what kind of results will I get? Stay tuned for that!! So I guess I should probably talk about some of the things that I
Don't like about the new iPhone X, and there's not very many. I know what you're saying, "Justine! You buy this!"
This is my video. I'm telling you the things that I like and I don't like. one of the things that I absolutely
do not like it all and it's been driving me insane is closing apps. Now Apple says that you don't have to close apps because
It doesn't really make a difference. It's not gonna kill your battery. It's not gonna do this
It's not gonna do that well. I like to close them
I like to be able to just go and swipe right down here at the bottom see the things that I have open not
Everything that I've opened in the past two months. The problem now is
to close apps you have to swipe up and you just hold and if there's a
There's a delay now normally. You would be able to just swipe up from here to close, but now you have to hold in and
then swipe up or
Hit this little button right her. So, it definitely takes a few extra seconds
Just to close some apps when before used to be super quick. Of course
This is a software thing so that is a very very easy fix. Hopefully in a future update of iOS 11. Oh gosh, speaking of updates.
Wow the biggest troll I feel like in internet history was the iOS
Bug where it turned the letter I to like an A with a question mark or something
there was a bunch of different things that were happening you would type a specific character whether it was an A or an I and
Then you would hit Send and in that sending process between you typing it and actually hitting Send on Twitter or Instagram or wherever
This would appear and most of the times when you were typing it you wouldn't actually see it until you hit Send
Are you posted of whatever it was you're posting and this
infected
Everyone because it wasn't just an iPhone 10 thing it was an iOS update it took them probably like four days
Maybe to fix it which I feel like is a pretty long time especially when the entire internet was just crumbling at our fingertips
Most people on Android couldn't see the issues so a lot of them are very confused as to what we were all complaining about or
What we were seeing the struggle was real
Thankfully that update has been updated so if you guys haven't updated to the latest software update on your iphones, please
Please too, It will save us all so much hassle. So I guess that's it
I really don't have much more to say that I haven't already said or I
Haven't already posted in a previous video if you guys want to watch all of those videos
I'll put a link in the description where you can check out my iPhone X playlist there's tons of fun videos there if you haven't
Seen them already, and if you have seen them. Thank you
I appreciate it. Be sure to subscribe because I have a bunch of fun holiday videos coming up
Which I'm very excited about. Also some more fun, Tech videos, some gaming videos
I know a lot of you guys have been requesting a Nintendo switch video, so yes
That is coming very very shortly as well. I feel so bad
I do so many things on this channel that when somebody gets super excited about something and they subscribe off of that specific video and
Then I don't do that thing again for a very long time
I just hope that you guys can find some entertainment in something here
And that's really my my only wish, really. Well that being said, I'm gonna go and edit this video now
So I will see you guys later. Bye